>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
HAPPY FRIDAY.
IN YOUR HEAD YOU ALWAYS IMAGINE
THE REVOLUTION WHEN IT STARTS
WILL START WITH TANKS AND
GUNFIRE, WITH CHAOS AND SOLDIERS
IN THE STREET.
YOU'LL KNOW WHEN IT COMES.
BUT IT NEVER DOES.
INSTEAD, THE REALLY BIG CHANGES
TO AMERICAN LIFE, THE PROFOUND
ONES THAT AFFECT ALL OF US
FOREVER, THOSE CHANGES ALMOST
ALWAYS BEGIN QUIETLY WITH GENTLE
PLEAS FOR TOLERANCE.
WE'D LIKE TO DO THINGS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY, THEY TELL YOU.
WE'D LIKE TO MAKE A CHANGE TO
SOME CUSTOMER BELIEF THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN ATTACHED TO FOR THE
LAST TWO THOUSAND YEARS, BUT
DON'T BE ALARMED, NOT A BIG
DEAL.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED TO
PARTICIPATE.
ALL WE ASK IS THAT YOU LET US
LIVE THE WAY WE WANT TO LIVE.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE PITCH.
AND, OF COURSE, YOU ALWAYS AGREE
TO IT.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU, WHO COULD SAY
NO.
SOME GUY DOWN THE STREET WANTS
TO WEAR A DRESS?
OKAY, FINE.
HAVE A PARTY.
IT DOESN'T AFFECT YOU.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WEAR A DRESS
SO GO AHEAD.
LIVE AND LET LIVE.
BUT IT TURNS OUT THAT'S NEVER
ACTUALLY THE DEAL.
THE GUY DOWN THE STREET WEARS
HIS DRESS BUT AFTER A WHILE
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR HIM.
HE'S STILL ANGRY.
AND FOR SOME REASON, HE'S ANGRY
WITH YOU.
AND THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
BECAUSE YOU'RE THE PERSON WHO
HAD NO PROBLEM WITH HIM WEARING
A DRESS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WHAT DID YOU DO WRONG?
WELL, THE PROBLEM IS, YOU'RE NOT
WEARING A DRESS, AND NEITHER ARE
YOUR KIDS.
YOUR NORMAL PERSON CLOTHES, THE
ONES YOU'VE ALWAYS WORN, ARE
SUDDENLY IMMORAL.
YOU'VE GOT TO CHANGE
IMMEDIATELY.
WHOA, WAIT A SECOND, YOU SAY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE AGREED TO.
YOU DO YOUR THING AND I'LL DO
MINE.
REMEMBER?
THEY DON'T REMEMBER.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
YOU DON'T GET TO DO YOUR THING
ANYMORE.
THE DRESS GUY'S IN CHARGE NOW.
EVERYBODY'S GOT TO DO HIS THING,
THE DRESS THING, OR FACE
PUNISHMENT.
THAT'S HOW IT GOES.
BE TOLERANT BECOMES SHOW SOME
RESPECT WHICH EVOLVES VERY
QUICKLY INTO BOW DOWN BEFORE US
AND LICK OUR FEET OR ELSE WE'LL
HURT YOU.
THAT'S THE FINAL STAGE.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE NOW.
FOR EXAMPLE, A DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER IN VIRGINIA CALLED
ELIZABETH GUZMAN IS INTRODUCING
A BILL THAT WILL CHARGE PARENTS
WITH A FELONY, STRIP THEM OF
THEIR EMPLOYMENT AND IMPRISON
THEM IF THEY DON'T
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ENDORSE THEIR
MINOR CHILDREN'S SEX CHANGES.
SO YOUR 12 YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
SAYS SHE WANTS A MASTECTOMY.
IF YOU OBJECT TO THAT IN ANY
WAY.
IF YOU RAISE QUESTIONS,
ELIZABETH GUZMAN WILL SEND YOU
TO JAIL FOR REAL.
HERE'S A LOCAL NEWS REPORT.
>> HER BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
STATE'S DEFINITION OF CHILD
ABUSE AND NEGLECT TO INCLUDE
PARENTS WHO DO NOT AFFIRM THEIR
CHILD'S GENDER IDENTITY OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
>> THERE'S AN INVESTIGATION ALSO
IN PLACE THAT IS NOT ONLY, YOU
KNOW, FROM A SOCIAL WORKER, BUT
THERE'S ALSO POLICE
INVESTIGATION BEFORE WE MAKE THE
DECISION THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE A CPS CHARGE.
>> WHAT COULD THE PENALTIES BE?
YOU KNOW THE INVESTIGATION
CONCLUDES AND HAS CONCLUDED THAT
A PARENT IS NOT AFFIRMING OF
THEIR LGBTQ CHILD, WHAT COULD
THE CONSEQUENCES BE?
>> WELL, WE FIRST HAVE TO HAVE
AN INVESTIGATION, YOU KNOW, IT
COULD BE A FELONY, IT COULD BE A
MISDEMEANOR BUT WE KNOW A CPS
CHARGE COULD HARM, YOU KNOW,
YOUR EMPLOYMENT, COULD HARM YOUR
EDUCATION.
>> Tucker: SO WHO IS THIS
ELIZABETH GUZMAN?
ELIZABETH GUZMAN CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY NOT SO LONG AGO FROM
PERU AS A SINGLE MOTHER.
NOW RATHER THAN WAIT A WHILE,
MAYBE SPEND A FEW GENERATIONS
HERE BEFORE TELLING YOU HOW TO
RAISE YOUR CHILDREN IN AMERICA,
SHE'S DECIDED TO GET RIGHT TO IT
AND COMPLETELY CHANGE
CHILD-REARING IN THIS COUNTRY IN
A WAY THAT WOULD NEVER BE
TOLERATED FOR A SECOND IN THE
COUNTRY FROM WHICH SHE COMES.
TRY THAT IN THE ANDEDIES HONEY
AND SEE HOW THAT WORKS.
YEAH.
BUT IN THIS COUNTRY, ACCORDING
TO ELIZABETH GUZMAN, YOU HAVE TO
AFFIRM YOUR CHILD ALLEYS SEX
CHANGE OR ELSE YOU'RE GOING TO
PRISON, AND THE STATE WILL RAISE
YOUR KIDS.
NOW, YOU'VE GOT TO THINK, MAYBE
THEY'VE WANTED THIS FOR A WHILE.
WHAT WOULD THIS MEAN?
WELL, IT WOULD MEAN FEWER INTACT
FAMILIES.
IT WOULD MEAN PEOPLE LIKE
ELIZABETH GUZMAN MAKE THE
MEANINGFUL DECISIONS IN YOUR
HOUSE.
IT MEANS LESS RESIST TRANSYOU,
AND MORE POWER FROM THEM.
WHAT IT DOESN'T MEAN IS THAT
ELIZABETH GUZMAN WILL BE
PROTECTING YOUR KIDS.
SHE DOESN'T EVEN CLAIM THIS LAW
PROTECTS YOUR KIDS.
SHE ACKNOWLEDGES THE WHOLE POINT
IS TO EDUCATE PARENTS.
RIGHT.
SO, LIKE THE COVID VACCINE, THIS
IS A PRETTY EASY WAY TO FIGURE
OUT WHO'S ON WHICH SIDE.
ARE YOU FOR THIS?
OKAY.
YOU'RE ON OUR TEAM.
YOU'RE WILLING TO SURRENDER
CONTROL OF YOUR OWN CHILDREN TO
ELIZABETH GUZMAN, WHO, AGAIN,
JUST GOT HERE.
BUT IF YOU'RE NOT FOR IT, THEN
WE KNOW YOU'RE NOT ON OUR TEAM.
WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
WE CAN SILENCE YOU.
WE CAN PUNISH YOU BECAUSE YOU
REFUSE TO BE EDUCATED.
SO IT'S A SIGNALLING MECHANISM,
AND YOU THAT BECAUSE THE
IDEOLOGY THAT UNDERLIES IT,
GENDER IDEOLOGY, IS COMPLETELY
INCOHERENT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AT
ALL.
IT IS NOT ROOTED IN SCIENCE.
IT'S A FORM OF RELIGION THAT'S
SO CRAZY IT DARES YOU TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
WHAT?
YOU CAN'T EVEN SAY THAT.
IF YOU DO, THEY KNOW YOU'RE ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
AND IT'S NOT JUST LUNATICS AND
EYED LAWINGS LIKE ELIZABETH
GUZMAN FROM PERU IT'S DOCTORS
AND MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
HERE'S ONE FROM BOSTON'S
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ONE OF THE
MOST FAMOUS IN THE WORLD WHICH
LIKE MANY IN THE UNITED STATES
AT THIS POINT UNDER THE JOE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CUTS THE
BREASTS OFF OF MINOR GIRLS FOR
NO MEDICALLY JUSTIFIABLE REASON.
WATCH A PRACTICING PSYCHOLOGIST,
AN ATTENDING PSYCHOLOGIST AT
BOSTON'S CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
EXPLAIN HOW EARLY CHILDREN CAN
BECOME TRAN.
>> SO MOST OF THE PATIENTS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE CLINIC ACTUALLY
KNOW THEIR GENDER USUALLY AROUND
THE AGE OF PUBERTY BUT A GOOD
PORTION OF CHILDREN DO KNOW AS
EARLY AS SEEMINGLY FROM THE WOMB
AND THEY WILL USUALLY EXPRESS
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY AS VERY
YOUNG CHILDREN SOME AS SOON AS
THEY CAN TALK.
THEY MAY SAY PHRASES LIKE I'M A
GIRL OR A BOY OR I'M GOING TO BE
A WOMAN OR I'M GOING TO BE A
MOM.
KIDS KNOW VERY, VERY EARLY.
SO IN THE CLINIC WE SEE A
VARIETY OF YOUNG CHILDREN ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO AGES TWO AND
THREE AND USUALLY UP TO THE AGES
OF NINE.
>> Tucker: SO THAT'S CARRIE
McGREGOR.
SHE'S A PSYCHOLOGIST.
SHE WORKS AT HARVARD.
I WONDER HOW MANY CHILDREN DOES
SHE HAVE, HAS SHE RAISED KIDS,
HAS SHE WATCHED THEM CAREFULLY?
DOES SHE KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
KIDS.
SHE'S TELLING YOU IF YOUR KID
SAYS MAYBE I'M THE OTHER SEX
THAT MEANS YOUR KID IS THE OTHER
SEX.
THAT'S INSANE BECAUSE ALMOST A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF KIDS AT ONE
POINT OR ANOTHER SAY THINGS LIKE
I THINK I'M A BOY OR GIRL, AND
YOU SMILE INDULGENTLY.
GET BACK TO ME IN 15 YEARS.
BUT NO SAYS CARRIE McGREGOR.
IN THE WOMB YOU CAN KNOW.
SO THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
TELLING YOU.
THEY'RE TELLING YOU THE
DEVELOPING CHILD IN THE WOMB IS
JUST A PART OF THE MOTHER.
THEREFORE, YOU CAN ABORT THAT
CHILD AT ANY TIME.
IT'S LIKE AN APPENDECTOMY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THAT SAME
CLUSTER OF CELLS, THAT FETUS,
CAN ALSO BE WOKE AND A SCRIBE TO
LEFT LIBERAL GENDER IDEOLOGY AND
YOU NEED TO HONOR THAT.
SO NO SANE PERSON COULD BELIEVE
ANY OF THIS VOLUNTARILY, DOESN'T
EVEN MAKE SENSE ON ITS FACE.
AGAIN IT'S A RELIGION AND IF YOU
RESIST IT THEY RESORT
IMMEDIATELY TO FORCE.
NO QUESTIONS ALLOWED.
AGAIN, THIS IS SCIENCE.
AND THE ESSENCE OF SCIENCE IS
RELENTLESS QUESTIONING ABOUT
WHAT YOU THINK YOU KNOW IS TRUE.
THAT IS THE SCIENTIFIC METHOD.
THAT'S SCIENCE ITSELF BUT NO
LONGER ALLOWED.
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WHICH HAS UTTERLY BEE CLOWNED
ITS SEVERAL ALONG WITH THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION JUST SENT A LETTER
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES DEMANDING THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND WE'RE
QUOTING TAKE SWIFT ACTION TO
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE HIGH
PROFILE USERS ON SOCIAL MEDIA
WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN, QUOTE,
DISINFORMATION.
YOU HATE TO ALWAYS INVOKE THE
GERMAN GOVERNMENT OF 80 YEARS
AGO, BUT WHAT ELSE IS THAT?
THAT'S TOTO TAL TARNISM.
THEY SAY IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
WHAT WE'RE DOING PEOPLE WITH
GUNS SHOULD COME AND TAKE YOU
AWAY.
YOU THINK SOMEONE IN THE MEDIA
WOULD POINT OUT, WOW, WE CAN'T
HAVE THAT IN THE UNITED STATES
WHERE PEOPLE ARE FREE TO BELIEVE
WHAT THEY WANT AND TO TALK ABOUT
IT IN PUBLIC AND TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
IN FACT THEY SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED TO.
BUT THE MEDIA DON'T SAY ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
THEY'RE JOINING WITH THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION,
THE AMA, TO CALL FOR MORE
CENSORSHIP AT GUNPOINT.
WATCH.
>> OBVIOUSLY THE QUESTION
BECOMES THEN, WHEN
MISINFORMATION, DISINFORMATION,
IS BEING SPREAD, WHEN HATE AND
THREATS ARE BEING SPREAD, WHERE
ARE THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES,
WHAT'S YOUTUBE DOING, WHAT'S
TWITTER DOING, AND THEN OF
COURSE YOU HAVE THE REACTION TO
THAT, OH, THIS IS BIG TECH
SILENCING PEOPLE, IT ALWAYS
BECOMES A DEBATE ABOUT FREE
SPEECH, DOESN'T IT?
>> YEAH, IT DOES.
YOU KNOW, LAST WEEK TWITTER
SUSPENDED LIBS OF TIK TOK,
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE POLICY
AGAINST THE PROMOTION OF THREATS
OF VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT.
SO GREAT JOB, RIGHT?
BUT IT'S BEEN SEVEN DAYS AND
LIBS OF TIK TOK IS BACK NOW AND
THEY'RE TWEETING RIGHT THIS VERY
MINUTE, THIS IS VIOLENCE, THIS
IS HARASSMENT.
IT'S CLEAR WHAT THESE ACCOUNTS
ARE DOING.
>> Tucker: IT'S SO FUNNY BACK TO
THE POINT AT THE OPEN.
WHEN THE REVOLUTION COMES THERE
WON'T BE TANKS OR SOLDIERS OR
STORM TROOPERS IN UNIFORMS AND
SYMBOLS IT WILL BE SOME
UNMARRIED 30 YEAR OLD WOMAN
TALKING IN A SING SONGY VOICE,
INFLECTION AT THE END, RIGHT?
RIGHT?
SPECIAL GLASSES OR COMPLEX
GLASSES THAT DON'T ACTUALLY
IMPROVE HER VISION.
SHE'LL HAVE ALL KINDS OF
POINTLESS HUMANITIES DEGREES AND
SHE WILL HE A BE ON CABLE NEWS
SAYING RIGHT?
IT'S VIOLENCE.
WHAT SHE'S REALLY SAYING IS,
SHUT UP AND OBEY OR WE'LL HURT
YOU.
SHE'S DELIVERING THE SAME
MESSAGE THAT A STORM TROOPER
DELIVERS BUT DOING IT IN A SING
SONGY WAY.
IT'S DISINFORMATION.
CALL US LITERAL BUT THIS IS THE
OPPOSITE OF DISINFORMATION.
IT'S NOT DISINFORMATION.
THIS IS LITERALLY WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING, BOSTON'S CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL AS WE JUST SHOWED YOU
ON TAPE IS TELLING YOU WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THEY PERFORMED DOUBLE
MASTECTOMIES ON MINORS FOR NO
MEDICAL REASON WHATSOEVER.
THAT'S INSANE.
IT OUGHT TO BE A CRIME IN A
CIVILIZED COUNTRY IT WOULD BE.
AND THEY KNOW THAT.
BECAUSE WHEN THEY WERE CAUGHT
THEY TRIED TO ERASE THE
EVIDENCE.
AND THEY'RE NOT ALONE.
UCSF, UWHEALTH IN WISCONSIN,
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN NEW YORK,
VANDERBILT HEALTH, CHILDREN'S
MINNESOTA, ALL OF THESE
HOSPITALS HAVE DELETED THE
EVIDENCE OF THEIR GENDER
AFFIRMING PROCEDURES, THEIR
GROTESQUE MUTILATION OF CHILDREN
AFTER THEY WERE PUBLICIZED,
THEIR OWN WORDS WERE PUBLICIZED
ON LINE.
NO ONE'S DIVERTING IT.
PEOPLE ARE JUST PUTTING UP THEIR
WORDS.
AND NOT ALL THE VIDEOS HAVE BEEN
DELETED.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS BIG INTO
THIS NOW BECAUSE IT'S LUCRATIVE.
SO HERE'S PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN
2021 TELLING CHILDREN THAT
SO-CALLED PUBERTY BLOCKERS ARE
HARMLESS.
RIGHT.
THAT'S A LIE.
AND BY THE WAY THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS A PUBERTY BLOCKER.
THESE DRUGS ARE HORMONE
ARGONISTS AND YOU CAN GET
PROSTATE CANCER AND THEY LOWER
YOUR TESTOSTERONE TO KEEP THE
CANCER FROM GROWING QUICKLY.
THEY'RE NOT APPROVED FOR PUBERTY
BLOCKING THEY'RE UNAPPROVED AND
THE LONG TERM AFFECTS ARE NOT
KNOWN BUT IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS
THEY'RE GRIM.
BUT PLANNED PARENTHOOD WON'T
TELL YOU THAT.
HERE'S THEIR VIDEO.
>> YOU'RE TRANSGENDER OR
NON-BINARY.
YOU MAY FIND YOUR PUBERTY
EXPERIENCES DON'T LINE UP WITH
YOURENDER I REMEMBEREDITY OR HOW
YOU SEE YOURSELF.
THAT FEELING CAN BE
UNCOMFORTABLE, SCARY AND
STRESSFUL.
IF THAT SOUNDS LIKE YOU, KNOW
THAT YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
THEIR MEDICINES YOU CAN TAKE TO
DELAY PUBERTY FOR A WHILE.
THEY'RE CALLED PUBERTY BLOCKERS
AND THEY WORK LIKE A STOP SIGN
BY HOLDING THE HORMONES,
TESTOSTERONE AND IS ENGINE THAT
CAUSE PUBERTY CHANGES LIKE
FACIAL HAIR GROWTH AND PERIODS.
PUBERTY BLOCKERS ARE SAFE AND
CAN GIVE YOU MORE TIME TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT FEELS RIGHT FOR YOU
YOUR BODY AND YOUR GENDER
IDENTITY.
>> EVERYTHING ABOUT THAT IS DARK
AND HORRIFYING AND THERE SHOULD
BE AN UPRISING AGAINST THAT.
THAT'S AIMED AT YOUR CHILDREN,
NOT AT ADULTS WHO CAN MAKE
RATIONAL DECISIONS BUT CHILDREN,
PEOPLE TOO YOUNG TO DRIVE OR
DRINK ALCOHOL OR SMOKE
CIGARETTES OR SERVE IN THE
MILITARY OR VOTE.
PEOPLE WE ARE NOT, WE HAVE
AGREED AS A GROUP, CAPABLE OF
MAKING RATIONAL ADULT DECISIONS
AND THAT'S AIMED AT THEM,
PROPAGANDA AIMED AT THEM AND A
LIE.
PUBERTY BLOCKERS ARE SAFE, THEY
HAVE NOT SAFE YOU CAN'T DELAY
PUBERTY WITHOUT DAMAGING
SEVERELY THE BODIES OF YOUNG
CHILDREN.
THE FDA IDENTIFIED SEVERAL QUOTE
CLINICALLY SERIOUS CASES OF SIDE
EFFECTS AFTER THESE DRUGS WERE
RECKLESSLY ADMINISTERED TO
CHILDREN BY LUNATIC EYED LOGS.
THEY FOUND A PLAUSIBLE
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN THE USE OF
PUBERTY BLOCKERS AND SOMETHING
CALLED INTRACRANIAL
HYPERTENSION.
YOU WANT THAT FOR YOUR 13 YEAR
OLD?
ACCORDING TO THE MAYO CLINIC
THAT CONDITION CAN CAUSE BRAIN
SWELLING, DOUBLE VISION, SEVERE
HEADACHES, PERMANENT VISION
LOSS.
IN OTHER WORDS, BRAIN DAMAGE.
BRAIN DAMAGE.
OH, GREAT, OKAY.
ON TOP OF THAT THE EUROPEAN
JOURNAL OF END INOLOGY AMONG
MANY OTHER PUBLICATIONS FOUND SO
CALLED PUBERTY BLOCKERS OFTEN
CAUSE QUOTE DECREASED BONE
DENSITY, WHICH IS ASSOCIATED
WITH A HIGH RISK OF OSTEO PA
ROSE.
AND OTHER PERMANENT SIDE EFFECTS
AS WELL.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THE SCOPE OF
THEM BECAUSE THIS HAS NEVER BEEN
TESTED LONGITUDE NATIONALLY
EVER.
THE EFFECTS ARE OBVIOUS AND IF
YOU POKE AROUND ON THE ABATIS
NET YOU WILL SEE THEM.
ONE TEEN-AGE GIRL UP LOADED A
VIDEO SHOWING FIVE YEARS OF
PUBERTY BLOCKERS ON HER.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHEN I TALK ABOUT BEING TOO
FAR GONE, I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT ELSE TO CALL IT, THIS IS
WHAT I MEAN.
THIS IS HOW DEEP MY VOICE IS.
IT'S GOTTEN DEEPER OVER TIME AND
IT'S SETTLED.
THIS IS WHAT I MEAN BY HEIR LOSS
AND IT JUST KEEPS GETTING WORSE,
KEEPS THINNING AND RECEDING
BACKWARDS.
YOU KNOW, AND I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE THAT'S COMING BACK.
THOSE ARE THE MAIN THINGS WHEN I
TALK ABOUT BEING A POINT OF NO
RETURN.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
GIVE A WOMAN TESTOSTERONE FOR
FIVE YEARS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS, THAT AND A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS.
THAT THEY'RE TELLING YOU IS
GENDER AFFIRMING?
IT'S MUTILATION GROTESQUE AND
DESTROYING PEOPLE'S LIVES,
CHILDREN'S LIVES.
WE MADE A DOCUMENTARY ON THIS
FOR TUCKER CARLSON ORIGINALS AND
WE TALKED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ENDURED SIMILAR TORTURE.
>> THIS TESTOSTERONE HAD THIS
EFFECT ON ME WHERE EVERY STEP
THAT I TOOK IT WOULD FEEL GOOD
FOR A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME BUT
THEN EVENTUALLY THOSE SAME
FEELINGS COME BACK UP.
>> THERE'S THE INITIAL EUPHORIA
THAT YOU GO THROUGH BY CHANGING
MY GENDER AND EVERYTHING'S GOING
TO BE WONDERFUL.
>> IT WAS EUPHORIC.
THE FEELING I HAD WHEN I STARTED
LIVING AS A MAN WAS, I WAS FREE,
I WAS FINALLY WHO I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ALL ALONG.
>> Tucker: BUT THAT EUPHORIA WAS
SHORT LIVED.
>> MY MENTAL HEALTH JUST GOT
WORSE.
MY ABILITY TO SOCIALIZE JUST GOT
I FELT SO DISCONNECTED FROM
MYSELF.
I STARTED USING LIKE DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL AS A CRUTCH, AND I WAS
JUST A TOTAL DISASTER.
AND THE EFFECTS OF THE
TESTOSTERONE ON MY MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIFICALLY JUST MADE
EVERYTHING TEN MILLION TIMES
WORSE.
>> I HAD BOUGHT INTO THE LIE.
IT ALMOST TOOK MY LIFE.
>> Tucker: IT'S JUST AWFUL.
AND EVERY PERSON WHO'S
PARTICIPATING IN THIS, IN THEIR
MOMENTS OF CLARITY KNOWS, THAT
TEN YEARS FROM NOW THERE WILL BE
THOUSANDS OF VOCAL VICTIMS OF
THIS MOMENT OF TRUE CRAZINESS
AND HYSTERIA THAT HAS GRIPPED
OUR COUNTRY.
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE BEING
DESTROYED RIGHT BEFORE US.
MOST ADULTS ARE TOO COWARDLY TO
SAY A WORD ABOUT IT.
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
ACTIVELY DOING ALL IT CAN TO
PROMOTE THIS, TO PROTECT
HOSPITALS THAT ARE MUTILATING
AND DESTROYING THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
ALWAYS A BELL WEATHER, A
LEGISLATOR CALLED SCOTT WEINER
JUST SPONSORED LEGISLATION TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA A SO-CALLED
SANCTUARY STATE FOR KIDS WHO
WANT TO MUTILATE THEIR OWN
BODIES, TO CASTRATE THEMSELVES.
SCOTT WEINER.
REALLY?
IS HE A GOOD FATHER?
WOULD YOU TRUST THIS GUY WITHIN
500 YARDS OF A CHILD?
PROBABLY NOT.
GAVIN NEWSOME JUST SIGNED THE
BILL, OF COURSE.
SO WHAT'S THE POINT HERE?
CERTAINLY NOT ON TO PROTECT
CHILDREN.
IT IS A NOT PROTECTING THEM.
ANY PARENT WILL TELL YOU, IF YOU
WANT TO PROTECT CHILDREN YOU
TELL THEM TO TAKE A DEEP BREATH
AND REACH ADULTHOOD AND THEN
MAKE RATIONAL DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW TO LIVE THEIR LIVES.
YOU WOULD DEFINITELY NOT LET
THEM MAKE A DECISION
IRREVERSIBLE DECISION LIKE THIS
FOR THEMSELVES.
YOU'RE THEIR PARENT.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT.
BUT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOESN'T
LIKE PARENTS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
REPLACING PARENTS WITH
THEMSELVES.
WE'RE IN CHARGE NOW.
IT'S THE MOST RECOGNIZABLE
POSSIBLE MOVE FOR ANY TO TAL
TARN MOVEMENT, BREAK UP THE
FAMILY REPLACE PARENTS WITH
POLITICIANS.